esta vez tenemos la derivada de james
con respecto a x igual a 4 james entre x
y bueno en este vídeo lo que veremos es
que la solución de una ecuación
diferencial no es un valor o un conjunto
de valores en cambio será una función o
un conjunto de funciones pero antes de
intentar resolverla o querer encontrar
todas las soluciones probemos con
algunas funciones para ver si son o no
soluciones de esta ecuación por ejemplo
qué pasa si trabajamos con ye
igual a 4x
será esta función solución de la
ecuación diferencial pausa el vídeo e
inténtalo
bueno para ver si esta función es
solución primero tenemos que encontrar
la derivada con respecto a equis y ver
si en efecto se cumple que esa derivada
es igual a cuatro veces ya entre x para
ello intentaré expresar todo en términos
de x y ver si obtenemos una igualdad
entonces primero encontremos cuál es la
derivada de que con respecto a x la cual
es simplemente cuatro ya hemos calculado
varias derivadas similares anteriormente
y por lo tanto queremos probar que 4 es
decir la derivada de ye con respecto a x
esto sea igual a 4 james entre x y
pondremos a quien como 4x porque vamos a
expresar todo en términos de x y
entonces me va a quedar que esto va a
ser igual a 4 por james pero lleva a
leer 4 x 4 x y esto a su vez dividido
entre x será cierta esta igualdad bueno
pues la x que divide y la x que
multiplica se cancela y me queda que 4
es igual a 16 lo cual no es cierto esto
no es cierto y entonces puedo decir que
esta función no es una solución en
ecuación diferencial
déjame escribirlo esta función no es
solución bien pensemos en otra función
que te parece esta vez tomarnos a james
igual a equis elevado a la cuarta
potencia será esta solución de mi
ecuación diferencial bueno de nuevo
pausa el vídeo e inténtalo
ok hagamos lo mismo cuál es la derivada
de james con respecto a x bueno si
utilizamos la regla de la potencia esto
me quedara común 4x elevado al cubo 4x
cúbica y entonces queremos comprobar que
4x cúbica sea lo mismo que cuatro veces
james pero recuerda james es lo mismo
que x cuarta entonces voy a expresar
todo en términos de x por james que es x
4a ok esto entre x será cierta esta
igualdad
veamos x cuarta entre x esto es lo mismo
que x kubica
entonces me queda que 4x kubica es igual
a 4 x cúbica y eso es cierto
por lo tanto esta función si es una
solución de mi ecuación diferencial no
es forzoso que sea la única solución
pero al menos es una solución a esta
ecuación diferencial así que le pondré
una palomita
muy bien ahora qué te parece si
agarramos otra ecuación diferencial
vamos a escribir otra ecuación
diferencial pero connotación distinta
imagina que tenemos la siguiente
ecuación diferencial f prima de x esto
es igual a efe de x
ya esto le voy a quitar x ok en la
primera función que quiero que probemos
es la función no sea jefe de x igual a
2x
es esta función solución de esta
ecuación diferencial para el vídeo e
intenta comprobar lo bueno para
comprobarlo necesitaremos encontrar a
efe prima tx efe prima de x en esta
ocasión va a ser simplemente 2 estás de
acuerdo y bueno ahora hay que comprobar
esta igualdad será cierto que 2 es igual
a efe de x pero fx en términos de x es
2x entonces voy a escribir 2x esto menos
x será cierto esta igualdad bueno de
aquí obtenemos que 2 es igual a x ahora
bien puede ser que estés tentado a decir
muy bien encontré un valor para x pero
realmente lo que nos dice esta expresión
es que está fx no
es una solución porque esto debe ser
cierto para todas x que se encuentren en
el dominio de la función no solamente
para una equis y entonces voy a indicar
que no está no es una solución déjame
escribirlo y en esto déjame ser muy
claro para que una función sea solución
de una ecuación diferencial debe
cumplirse esta igualdad para todas x que
pongas en la función bien veamos otra
función más pensemos ahora en fx igual a
bueno que tal x + 1
será esta función solución de esta
ecuación diferencial ok de nuevo pausa
el vídeo e inténtalo
ok hagamos el mismo procedimiento tienes
efe prima de x
bueno esto va a ser simplemente la
derivada de x con respecto x es 1 y la
derivada de 1 con respecto a x es 0
entonces me quedara una y entonces
queremos probar que efe prima de x es
decir 1 sea igual a fx pero expresada en
términos de x es x + 1 x + 1
+ 1 y esto menos x y abraham observa no
importa que x pongas aquí siempre se va
a cumplir esta ecuación siempre se va a
cumplir que uno es igual a uno y
entonces ahora sí puedo decir que esta
de aquí si es solución de ecuación
diferencial muy bien probemos con otra
función más para eso de que me bajar la
pantalla y me voy a quedar con mi
ecuación diferencial que escribí de
color morado con mi segunda ecuación
diferencial y ahora quiero probar otra
función se me ocurre tomar la función
efe de x igual a
y elevado a la equis ok más x más 1 será
esta una solución de la segunda ecuación
diferencial bueno pausa de nuevo el
vídeo e intenta encontrar la respuesta
bien primero encontremos la derivada de
esta función
efe prima de x y la derivada de esta
función va a ser igual
tengo la derivada de a la x con respecto
a x bueno esto es simplemente a la x que
hasta el día de hoy me parece
sorprendente ya esto le sumamos la
derivada de x con respecto a x lo cual
es 1 o que ésta es mi derivada y ahora
sustituyamos todo esto en nuestra
ecuación diferencial dicen f prima de x
pero f prima de x es el elevado a la x
más 1
esto debe de ser igual a bueno a fx que
es toda esta expresión
elevado a la x + x + 1 ok ya esto le
tenemos que quitar x será cierta esta
igualdad bueno pues es cierto porque
esta x y esta x se cancelan y me queda
simplemente elevado a la x + 1 así que
en efecto esta otra función también es
solución déjame anotarlo y ya está con
esto hemos acabado nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo
hasta la próxima